what's the best part of this chapter and
you know being married to Ben there's so
many things I mean I I couldn't I you
don't have enough time right now
Jennifer Lopez and Jennifer Garner
bonding over motherhood and their new
blended family that's right Source tells
E.T the gens have a very healthy and
functioning relationship they're both
great dedicated moms and can connect
over that it's a juggling act the kids
are growing together as a new extended
family home is about where the people
you love are it doesn't matter what you
know place you are as for the exes
things between Jen Garner and Ben are
healthy in terms of co-parenting I'm
gonna do our best we don't try our best
our source says they both are working to
make the transition the best it could
possibly be it's great adding Jen Garner
just wants her kids to feel comfortable
she's in a great space and feels good
about the new family Dynamic and the
kids seem to be adjusting just fine last
month Jen was spotted taking her child
Seraphina and JLo's child Emmy to
Disneyland you can't buy parenting you
have to get down on the floor and play
at least a little bit even if you're a
super busy mom or dad you have to find
time for your kids and benefit will have
plenty of room to host the whole fam in
this 60 million dollar Mega Mansion they
just bought
[Music]
according to our source benefit couldn't
be more thrilled about this new chapter
we're super happy Jennifer and Ben are
looking forward to connecting their
families they also can't wait to host
holiday parties together and to have
family and friends over for fun
occasions
the five acre Beverly Hills Home
features 12 bedrooms 24 bathrooms it's
just a dream come true one massive Pool
Plus an indoor sports complex with a
basketball court pickleball court gym
boxing ring and a lounge it's like a
whole nother level yep sounds like the
perfect home for the big happy blended
family what can I tell you we're just
having a good time